given how much we all long to be happy
we might presume that accepting the
possibility of happiness in our lives
would be an uncomplicated serene and
automatic process but for many of us
however theoretically attached we might
be to the notion of being happy the
possibility of actually being so is
liable to trigger deep ambivalence and
fear we would it appears often prefer to
be worried and sad rather than attempt
to take on the risks surreptitiously
connected in our minds with positive
moods we may however paradoxical it
sounds be nothing less than afraid to be
happy as ever our fear has a history
that probably begins in childhood where
one of the following is likely to have
occurred someone we deeply loved and
perhaps admired to was unhappy their
sorrow moved us profoundly and led us to
identify with them so that our caution
around contentment continues to function
as a kind of secret tribute to them to
be happy would in a way that would pain
us profoundly mean being disloyal
however much they might on the surface
have encouraged us to venture out and
seize opportunities for joy an important
part of us wishes to stay with them
under the canopy of grief so without
knowing we're doing this we ensure that
we'll always have a modest career
because they never had educational
possibilities or we turn down sexual
opportunities because they were sexually
neglected alternatively someone we were
close to might have been jealous of us
and led us to want to downplay our
achievements and hide our contentment in
order to feel safe from their envy and
rage we learn to associate gloom with
safety and joy with risk more generally
we may have lacked any plausible role
models for happiness we may have grown
up in an environment where being anxious
and panicky was just the default state
where it seemed natural to picture the
plane crashing the police
showing up the business collapsing and
the mold morphing into cancer
we may be intellectually aware that
there could be other ways to interpret
the future but calm doesn't feel like
what our tribe naturally does to this
resistance we might have added a layer
of intellectual superiority happiness
could seem for the little people the
leading symptom of understanding the
world intelligently must be sadness we
might think all such positions
contribute to a psyche where the onset
of happiness is a cause for grave and
glaring alarm when we're finally on
holiday or in love or surrounded by
friends or free of financial pressure we
panic our senses have been jammed for so
long in the fear mode they're filled
with dread even when the alarm stops
wailing to return to a more balanced
state we're liable systematically to
sabotage the conditions of contentment
we start working on holiday and soon
uncover a cause for alarm at the office
within hours we may be protesting that
we need to return home or else we do our
utmost to convince a new lover that
we're not really worth it by seldom
calling them or if they really don't get
the message having an affair it feels so
much more normal to be abandoned in
order to acclimatize ourselves to
happiness
we need to return to the past and unpick
how we learned to use anxiety as a
defensive strategy to protect us against
other threats we were too young and too
easily overwhelmed to answer the manic
warrior worries as it were about
everything because they're unable to be
appropriately concerned with and in
mourning for one or two big things from
long ago the anxiety that belonged to
one particular distant time and place
has been redistributed and subdivided
across hundreds of ever-shifting topics
in the present from workplace to
reputation money to household tasks
because it's true source and origins
remain unknown to the sufferer we're
using the flotsam and jetsam of everyday
worries as a proxy for an unmask
turrible trauma shame humiliation as
since we don't matter to our caregivers
neglect or abuse
we should not sarcastically point out to
warriors that they need something else
to worry about we should realize that
something terrifying that they have
buried deep in their unconscious is
lending a continuous sense of dread to
their fragile present we manic warriors
need not sarcasm but supportive and
intelligent company to give us the love
we need to dare to look back at the past
and the insight with which to try to do
so our dread is a symptom of an ancient
sorrow a sign that we keep not finding
anything in the outer world that answers
to the horror of the inner one needless
to say it isn't the case that there is
never anything to worry about in the
present just that there is a lot less
than the manic warrior tends to believe
furthermore what there is to worry about
can be coped with with far more
resilience and the manic warrior can
imagine that they are operating with
what is essentially a child's sense of
their own powers and capacities for
survival manic warriors should gradually
come to exchange their feelings of dread
for the future for a patient
understanding and morning for an
unfairly traumatic and as yet
insufficiently explored past
there is nothing greedy or stupid about
happiness the ability to take
appropriate satisfaction from the good
times is a profound psychological
achievement it is a mark of deep
seriousness to be able to giggle have a
pillow fight with a child delight in a
fig or an orange sunbathe sometimes
knock off work early to have an ice
cream and appreciate a daffodil sorrow
is obvious there is always a richness of
reasons to despair fear is safe as well
if we're waiting for the enemy with a
sword in hand we may gain a vital few
seconds with a blow to come but the
truly courageous and heroic ly defiant
move would be to dare to put down our
weapon lessen our preparations for
catastrophe resist the terrors ingrained
in us over decades and once in a while
believe that astonishingly for a time
there might truly be
nothing to worry about
our emotional barometer is a tool that
can help us to more clearly explain our
moods click the link on screen now to
find out more
you